- [Instructor] In this video,
we're gonna think about
how we can use our knowledge
of multiplying single digit
numbers to multiply things
that might involve two digits.
So for example, let's start
with, what is five times 18?
And you can pause the video
and see how you might try
to approach this, and
then we'll do it together.
All right, so if we're trying
to tackle five times 18,
one strategy could be to
say, hey, can I re-express 18
as the product of two numbers?
And the one that jumps
out at me is that 18
is the same thing as two times nine,
and so I could rewrite five times 18.
This is the same thing as five
times, instead of 18, I
can write two times nine.
Now, why does this help us?
Well, instead of multiplying
the two times nine first
to get the 18, and then
multiplying that by five,
what we could do is we
could multiply the five
times the two first.
And you might be thinking,
wait, wait, wait,
hold on a second.
Before, you did the two times nine first,
and now, you're telling me
that you're going to change the order?
That you're going to say, hey,
let's multiply the five times
two first, is that okay?
And the simple answer is, yes, it is okay.
If you are multiplying
a string of numbers,
you can do them in any
order that you choose,
and so this is often known
as the associative
property of multiplication.
We can associate the
two with the nine first.
We can multiply those first,
or we can have an association
with the five and the two.
We can multiply those two first.
Now, why is that helpful?
Well, what is five times two?
Well, that's pretty straightforward.
That's going to be equal to 10.
So this is going to be equal to 10.
We're doing that same color.
10 times nine.
Now, 10 times nine is a
lot more straightforward
for most of us than five times 18.
10 times nine is equal to 90.
Let's do another example.
Let's say we wanna figure
out what three times 21 is.
Pause this video and see if
you can work through that.
There's multiple ways to do it,
but see if you can do it the way
we just approached this first example.
Well, as you could image,
we want to re-express 21
as the product of smaller numbers.
So we could rewrite 21 as
three times seven maybe?
And so if we rewrite it
as three times seven,
and now, we do the
three times three first.
So I'm just gonna put parenthesis
there, which we can do
because the associative
property of multiplication.
Fancy word for something
that is hopefully a little bit intuitive.
Well then, this is going to be equal to,
what's three times three?
It is nine,
and then times seven,
which you may already know
is equal to 63.
Let's do another example.
This is kinda fun.
Let's say we wanna figure
out what 14 times five is.
Pause this video and see
if you can figure that out.
Well, we could once
again try to break up 14
into the product of smaller numbers.
14 is two times seven,
so we can rewrite this as two times seven
or as seven times two,
and I'm writing it as seven times two,
because I want to associate
the two with the five
to get the 10 times five,
and then I can multiply
the two times five first.
And so this is going to
give us seven times 10,
seven times 10, which is
of course equal to 70.
One more example.
Let's say we want to
calculate 15 times three.
How would you tackle that?
Well, we can break up 15
into five times three.
Five times three,
and then we can multiply that,
of course, by this three,
and then we can multiply
the threes together first,
and then this amounts to five times nine.
And five times nine,
you might already be familiar with this.
This is going to be equal to 45.
Another way to get to
45, you can say, hey,
five times 10 is 50.
So five times 9 is going
to be five less than that,
which is also 45.